c'est exceptionnel ce qui s'est passé
puisque barbara prévient eh oui la
chanteuse française est arrivée deuxième
de l'eurovision
j'ai cru toute la soirée qu'elle avait
gagné on va revoir sa prestation
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est sympa mais cinq minutes alex
êtes fier de cette deuxième place je
suis fier je suis heureux c'est
absolument incroyable ce qui s'est passé
on a une artiste est magique et
charismatique et quelle chance
finalement calé représenter la france
avec cette culture et cette chanson
française qui finalement elle est là et
elle traverse l'europe donc plus fier
que jamais de cette deuxième place et
c'est pour nous une véritable victoire
même si on n'a pas la première viendra
parler de moi je vous dis la vérité on
va se dire les choses
vous êtes bien content de terminer prix
bas s'ils arrivent à pasqua pour
l'organisation sa canne on le connaît
j'étais avec delphine ernotte ce n'était
pas très fourni en off arrêté c'est la
patronne vont sévir j'ai fait deux fois
mais bien de chez nous disaient les
patrons de france télévisions et non
michy roman policier au plus haut point
sur vos barrières ne sont pas les
patrons dont je dois te dire s'ils
veulent pas qu'on volé puisque c'est
l'état le patron c'est le même mentir
bien mais qu'on avait organisé et
l'année prochaine on espère pour
l'organisation
je le dis aux téléspectateurs niort je
vais vous dire ce que 10 mars à ce que
dit les sionistes et patron de constellé
avant de partir et vous dise la plus
grosse tuile qui pourrait nous arriver
c'est de gagner la meilleure chose ça
peut nous arriver c'est de finir dans
les cinq premiers
deuxième ça serait la meilleure place
donc là c'est vrai que c'est
exceptionnel
deuxième c'est la meilleure place et
pourquoi parce que si vous êtes premier
vous devez organiser l'année prochaine
et l'année d'après je vous dire ça coûte
30 bar cette affaire à 31
oui on organise l'eurovision junior et
on est super contents et l'eurovision
junior c'est pas mal aussi
je vais y aller que dans ce cas et j'ai
rien à dire la vérité et toute la vérité
delphine et stéphane ont très envie
d'organiser l'eurovision bientôt ksari
alors j'adore d'attiser stéphane
boudsocq si je vous dis si on avait
gagné cette année ne saurait un bordel
pas possible je vous le dis ça aurait
été un bordel sami fehri dentielle
d'ailleurs regardez il ya
là on est à un moment parce que ça se
bousculait en suisse qu'en suisse france
et puis l'italie et arié merci